let's return now to the fears of the new
covid variant omicron two cases have now
been identified on british soil but it
was first detected in south africa
a little earlier today i spoke to
professor barry shube chair of south
africa's ministerial advisory committee
on kobit 19 vaccines
i began by asking him how quickly this
new strain is spreading
it isn't spreading very rapidly
in fact if you look at about what 10
days ago we were about 283 new cases a
day we are now just over 3 3200.
uh saw very much very much less than
what you've got the united united
kingdom about a tenth of it but it is
spreading rapidly it started off in the
carting province around johannesburg and
then is now certainly spreading to other
provinces as well
how worried are you about this uh the
question that's being asked here is will
it displace
delta
yeah that's that's really the question
actually that you're wrestling with
because you know it's got many many more
mutations in delta delta's got probably
about 16 identified mutations this has
got over 30 in the spike protein the
critical part of the virus so that makes
it uh really a variant of concern and i
think it's going to be called a variant
of them or labeled a variation of
concerns so we are worried about it
but i suppose we're trying to always to
look at the light at the end of the
tunnel and this is speculation i must
stress it's just speculation but because
it's got all these mutations does it in
fact destabilize the virus it might make
it less fit than delta
and in a way hopefully it won't displace
delta because uh delta we know
uh responds very well to the vaccine but
at the moment it's certainly becoming
the dominant
of the isis that you looked at
the dominant uh variant but uh it
doesn't mean to say that always remain
that way
so
even if it does go away uh relatively
speaking quickly while it is here
what is what are the signs about its
virulence the extent to which it's
serious and will cause hospitalizations
yeah it's it's early days we don't know
as yet that's the bottom line
uh there is a little bit there's an
optimistic view
that so far the cases have been pretty
mild and if you know we have a hospital
surveillance program as well and that
hasn't shown any significant uptick
so certainly the cases that that that
have occurred so far have all been mild
cases mild to moderate cases and that's
a good sign but let me stress it is
early days you still have to wait and
see
do you have any idea yet
how this mutation came about is it just
uh
a freak is it just some
something that you might expect in the
normal course of events or is there
anything special about the origins of
this
well you know this is a virus it's a
it's a plastic virus in other words it
tends to mutate very very regularly very
readily
and
under conditions where
it is mutating particularly in people
who might be partially immunosuppressed
in other words where they're not getting
rid of the virus then those via that
remnant virus which remains will be
selectively enriched to escape immunity
and to become more transmissible
so i think that's probably where it does
arise
to land to a large extent unvaccinated
people because they're a reservoir of
the virus the virus multiplying and also
to a large extent people who are
immunosuppressed or partially men are
suppressed because they're not clearing
the virus where they do get infected
um
it's being
said that uh speaking of
immunosuppression that
one of the
particular factors in south africa has
been the spread of hiv there
do you credit that do you think that's
part of the story
it may be part of the story it would
seem logical that it could be uh but you
know there are many causes of
immunosuppression not only people living
with hiv who aren't on treatment people
who aren't treatment too well controlled
that would not be a problem they they
are immunocompetent like like the rest
of us would be
but
it may well be a problem in those that
are not well controlled not on treatment
who not haven't started treatment yet it
may be a vector
the big question of course that
everybody is wondering about and we may
not have the information yet but do you
have any thought about the efficacy of
the existing vaccines against this
variant
yeah again it's it's just early days
there are uh there are there's a great
there's a frenzy of activity let me put
it that way uh doing what we call the
neutralization antibody tests
uh you know testing for uh how
neutralizing antibodies behave against
this particular variant has been done
particularly in two laboratories in
south africa
and hopefully we'll get those that data
fairly soon because obviously it's
critical data
so at this stage
we don't really know i think we can be a
little bit optimistic because we do know
that the vaccine does behave well
against the pre-existing variants and
those mutations are what happens what
what is present in the previous variance
what is unknown is that this
constellation of mutants
will that kind of enhance what we call
vaccine escape that we don't know yet
but we are optimistic and i think we can
be fairly comfortably optimistic
that the vaccine will at least
particularly against severe disease i
think that's the bottom line
broadly speaking from what you've been
saying uh this morning professor uh
though
you seem to you are of course thinking
about what we should do
you you seem to be saying we shouldn't
be too alarmed at this stage
i think alarms is too strong a word i i
would say certainly concerned
we are concerned in this country with
the expansion we're going we're heading
into our fourth wave so that that that
is a there's cause for concern and i
think which should motivate people to do
two things one of them is that they have
to we need to up on this country our
vaccination coverage we're not we're not
certainly not anywhere near what we
should be that's the one thing we need
to impress on people to get vaccinated
and secondly we also need to impress
some people that we still need to
carry out those infection prevention
measures you know the masking the social
justice etc the advice is still around
it's still expanding and even if one is
vaccinated there's no guaranteed that
you're not going to get infected as no
guarantee you're not going to pass it on
so those are the two things vaccination
and also infection prevention measures
and
are the infection prevention measures
masking so on working in south africa
yocho that's a difficult one to really
answer uh
i i think you know if you compare to
enough for example united kingdom a lot
more people yeah are wearing moss are
trying
to avoid the social functions you know
the problem is of course we're coming to
the end of our end of our year our end
of our academic year end of our school
year so and uh also it's coming to the
christmas holidays so that's a problem
because uh there are parties and so on
and uh
i i think we're trying to kind of
impress on people i think this variant
uh is probably going to be a bit of a
kind of a wake-up call
and also the expansion of infection is
going to be a wake-up call so i can just
hope yes that there will be an
improvement in infection uh prevention
adherence
just one last quick question professor
people
here are campaigning about the number of
vaccines they say maybe about a couple
of hundred million doses which are
essentially uh sitting unused in rich
countries do you think rich countries
are doing enough to support countries
like yours absolutely not
absolutely not
i think this is a major global ethical
problem
uh
the reason why we have these variants is
because the world is not is not
vaccinated
if if there was a an equitable
distribution of that particularly to the
african continent which is really being
deprived of vaccines
and the rich countries are hoarding
hoarding vaccines there's no doubt about
it i think this is a really a blot
on the behavior of
of the
of the wealthy countries
professor barry shube thank you very
much indeed